hey guys how's it going it's Justine
we're back here with another fun summer
snack video if you're just joining us
here this week I've been doing a video
every week that is kind of inspired by
summer so there's a link in the
description that will take you to all of
this week's videos but now we are going
to make something that I've never made
myself but I've had it before and it's
really really good it's a Vietnamese
coffee so for this we're gonna need
water condensed milk I already made the
coffee hold on I gotta move this camera
cuz this is where the can opener would
be awesome it's earlier today I made
some ice cubes made out of coffee
actually Jenna made them for me I got
this little ice cube tray on Amazon go
figure
so we're gonna use these as ice god this
is gross dude this is one tablespoon
okay well why are you on this thing
what's wrong really can you take my
phone Jenna's gonna girlfriend charlie
all right so it's 2 tablespoons of this
is this is a 1 table of condensed milk
this is gross we'll just put that in
there and 2
well I've made a mess through oh boy
this almost didn't fit
Wow drop you in there buddy that's great
looking good now says pour the hot
coffee over the ice cubes and then stir
briskly this probably isn't a dark
enough roast but I'll do what I gotta do
all right time to try it oh that's good
this is definitely a heavier coffee
drink so is it something you probably
shouldn't have every day thank you guys
so much for watching let me know what
your favorite video has been so far and
let me know if you guys have tried any
of these recipes that I've done here on
the summer snack week I'll see you guys
tomorrow for another video leave me some
comments below and let me know what you
think I'm gonna make and be sure to
check out the rest of the videos that
I've already posted this week so gone so
good